Queridos amigos, amigas, voy a empezar
planteándoos un reto, atentos a los datos.
Imaginad que tenemos un país con una
inflación por encima del 50% anual,
donde casi la mitad de la población vive en
la pobreza, un país con muy pocos empleos de
calidad y que tiene una escasez crónica
de divisas extranjeras e inversiones.
Un país que lleva décadas experimentando una
situación de crisis económica, política y
social casi constante y que se ha quedado muy
atrasado en cuanto a tecnología productiva.
Vamos, que las cosas no pueden
seguir así, os enfrentáis a un
escenario insostenible. Una situación
en la que sentarse y tomar decisiones.
La pregunta es, si vosotros estuvierais
a los mandos. ¿Qué decisiones tomaríais?
Pues bien, estoy seguro que con
semejantes problemas internos
una de las soluciones que muchos
pondríais sobre la mesa sería:
este país tiene que volcarse
claramente al comercio exterior.
Al fin y al cabo eso le permitiría
conseguir un montón de divisas,
crear nuevos puestos de trabajo, atraer nuevas
inversiones, hacerse con nuevas tecnologías,
nuevos mercados y un largo etcétera de beneficios.
Es una fórmula que han empleado muchísimos
gobiernos a lo largo y ancho de todo el mundo,
desde España hasta Japón, pasando
por Polonia, China o Singapur.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos,
amigas, hay un país con muchos,
muchísimos más problemas de los
que hemos descrito en este vídeo,
en el que sin embargo el término comercio
internacional suena prácticamente a herejía.
Por supuesto, me estoy refiriendo a la
Argentina. Un país, querida comunidad,
que parece alérgico al mundo exterior.
Ahora bien, ¿Por qué la Argentina es
tan hostil al comercio exterior? ¿Qué
trabas existen? ¿Cómo podría el país del tango y
los asados muy hechos hacer del comercio
exterior una enorme fuente de riqueza?
En este vídeo vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas, pero antes,
antes tenemos que ver dónde comenzó todo.
Atentos.
(DE LA GLOBALIZACIÓN AL AISLAMIENTO)
La Argentina era un país despoblado y pobre, hasta
que en el siglo XIX se produjo un enorme cambio
social y económico. El país se abrió al mundo
y comenzaron a llegar millones de inmigrantes
e inversiones que permitieron poner a trabajar
las grandes extensiones de la Pampa Húmeda.
(Poco a poco la Argentina se convirtió
en el “granero del mundo” y también en
uno de los países más prósperos de toda
la tierra . Los ferrocarriles trasladaban
a los puertos de Rosario y Buenos Aires
el producto del campo conseguido con el
arduo trabajo de los inmigrantes europeos que
habían llegado al país en búsqueda de riqueza.
De esta forma las ciudades crecían,
las inversiones se acumulaban y el
país tenía su propia versión del sueño americano.)
Sin embargo, todo empezó a cambiar cuando
en 1929 se desató la gran crisis. Una crisis
que tuvo su origen en los Estados Unidos pero
que pronto se extendió por el resto del mundo.
Y Argentina no fue una excepción. A
partir de ese momento fueron muchos
los que señalaron al comercio internacional,
a las fronteras abiertas y al patrón oro
de ser los ingredientes clave de la crisis.
Algo que provocó una enorme ola de nacionalismo,
intervencionismo y proteccionismo
en la política mundial.
Y aquí, amigos, la Argentina
fue un alumno destacado.
(El liberalismo económico y la economía
agroexportadora que hasta entonces habían
caracterizado al país gaucho pasaron a
ser considerados como un modelo anticuado.
La opinión mayoritaria comenzó a inclinarse por
que el país se enfocara en llevar a
cabo un proceso de industrialización
interna que le permitiera no depender de las
fluctuaciones de la economía internacional.)
Unas ideas que se consolidaron con
el estallido de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y sobre todo con la llegada al
poder en 1946 de Juan Domingo Perón.
A partir de ese momento, el país se iría
cerrando poco a poco a la economía mundial
siguiendo la conocida como Política
de Sustitución de Importaciones. Un
tipo de política que tuvo su punto
álgido a partir de los años 70.
De hecho uno de los libros que más ha influido
a los economistas argentinos es la obra titulada
“vivir con lo nuestro” que a comienzos de los 80
publicó el Paul Krugman argentino, Aldo Ferrer.
[“Vivir con lo nuestro”. No sé, creo
que no hace falta mucha presentación.]
El caso es que con el breve paréntesis de la
presidencia de Menem, de la que por cierto,
ya os hablamos aquí en VisualPolitik,
los políticos argentinos han trabajado
duro por aislar al país del mundo.
[Bueno, excepto si hablamos de
los dólares del Fondo Monetario
Internacional. Ahí ya sabéis que
los políticos argentinos siempre
ponen primero la mano y luego cuanto
toca pagar un millón de excusas.]
Argentina, amigos, lejos de promover las
exportaciones ha levantado todo tipo de
barreras al comercio exterior. Lo
que resulta un caso completamente
paradigmático en la política internacional.
Y, ojo, porque hablamos de una tarea
que los políticos se han tomado muy
pero que muy en serio. Incluso cuando
los resultados han sido calamitosos,
no sólo no han cambiado de rumbo,
sino que han pisado el acelerador.
¿Y sabéis qué? Eso precisamente es lo que está
haciendo el actual presidente Alberto Fernández.
Atentos.
(EN BUSCA DEL DÓLAR)
Lo más sorprendente del caso argentino, no es que
los políticos se hayan obsesionado
con poner trabas a las importaciones
con la excusa de fomentar la industria
nacional y evitar la pérdida de divisas.
Eso es algo que han hecho otros
muchos gobiernos del mundo.
[Y que, por cierto, siempre termina mal.
Entre otras cosas porque se perjudica la
competencia y el uso de inputs
más baratos o tecnológicamente
más avanzados al tiempo que
se generan mercados cautivos.]
No, lo más llamativo del caso
argentino es que un país que
necesita desesperadamente dólares,
castigue las propias exportaciones.
Si, si, tal cual como lo escucháis. El
gobierno argentino no para de entorpecer
las operaciones con el exterior,
ya sea para comprar o para ver.
Da igual, si eres un empresario argentino
y quieres comerciar con el
extranjero… Eres sospechoso.
Ahora bien, la pregunta es, ¿Cómo
lo hace exactamente? ¿Qué mecanismos
utiliza el gobierno argentino para
torpedear el comercio internacional?
Pues, veréis, actualmente la primera
clave está en los controles de capitales.
Esto es, en las normas que el gobierno ha
fijado para los argentinos que quieran comprar,
vender y mover dólares, que cómo todos sabéis
es la divisa de referencia del comercio mundial.
Unos controles que han provocado que en el
país gaucho encontremos dos tipos de cambio:
(Por un lado, está el tipo de cambio oficial
que en el momento de preparar este vídeo viene
a ser de unos 104 pesos por dólar, y por
otro lado tenemos el tipo de cambio libre
en el mercado informal, más conocido como
el tipo de cambio del dólar blue, donde,
para que os hagáis una idea, el el dólar viene a
costar el doble: unos 220 pesos por cada dólar.)
Por supuesto, todas las operaciones bancarias
se realizan teniendo en cuenta el dólar oficial,
que como veréis no resulta
tan sencillo de conseguir.
Pero, empecemos si os parece por ver qué ocurre
con las compras, esto es, con las importaciones.
Cualquier empresa grande, mediana o pequeña,
que necesite importar productos del extranjero
debe hacer frente a un largo laberinto de
trámites y formularios que a la hora de
la verdad le van a hacer muy difícil
conseguir las divisas que necesita.
Fijaos, para poder importar productos
las empresas tienen que obtener una LNA;
una licencia no automática
de Importación. Licencias que
el estado argentino concede de
forma totalmente discrecional.
Es decir, que solo podrás hacerte
con una si el funcionario de turno
considera que tu petición de comprar
en el extranjero tiene o no sentido.
De esta forma, los interesados están obligados a
explicar para qué y por qué quieren las divisas,
pedirlas con un montón de antelación y
rezar porque el funcionario encargado
del caso escuche sus plegarias y
tenga a bien darles la licencia.
[Si no le da la gana, pues como se dice en España,
Ajo y agua. Aguantarse y… Bueno, pues eso.]
(De esta forma el gobierno argentino
controla el volumen de importaciones
que entran al país. Y si de repente las divisas
del banco central se reducen muy rápido pues…
se cierra el grifo y se desestiman
muchas más licencias de lo normal.
Aunque eso, claro está, suponga un
castigo muy duro para las empresas
locales que pueden enfrentarse de la
noche a la mañana a la incapacidad de
obtener materias primas o productos del
extranjero necesarios para su actividad.)
Mala suerte. Esto, amigos, es lo
que explica que en la Argentina
sea habitual que las empresas se enfrenten
a una escasez recurrente de materiales que,
por ejemplo, les puede impedir mejorar
la producción o reparar una máquina.
Así que ya lo véis, el dólar oficial en
Argentina es barato pero viene con trampa.
Eso sí, un momento, si te llevas bien con el
gobierno, puedes tener una fuente
inagotable de riqueza. ¿Por qué?
Pues porque de facto al fijar un
tipo oficial que no tiene nada que
ver con el tipo de mercado lo que
hace el gobierno es subvencionarte
las compras en el extranjero. Pero insisto,
eso siempre y cuando tengas su bendición.
[Sí, lo sé, es un sistema espantoso.]
Bien, esto respecto a las importaciones, pero,
¿Qué ocurre con las exportaciones?¿Con
las ventas al extranjero?
Pues, amigos, de entrada si exportas un
producto y consigues dólares, el gobierno
te los va a convertir forzosamente en pesos… Al
tipo de cambio oficial. Es decir, a 104 pesos
por dólar y no a 220, que es a lo que cotiza el
blue dólar en el momento de preparar este vídeo.
M(El problema es que la economía de
Argentina, ante el desastre del peso,
está en gran medida dolarizada.
De esta forma, los costes de las
empresas se determinan en muchos casos
por el tipo de cambio del dólar blue.
Es decir, que cuando una empresa decide
exportar su producción lo que va recibir
son pesos a un tipo de cambio que
es la mitad de lo que valen en el
mercados los dólares que el gobierno le arrebata.)
Para entendernos, que cuando una
empresa argentina quiere importar algo,
se beneficia del dólar barato, el problema es
que no tiene garantizado que pueda acceder a
los dólares. Y cuando quiere exportar,
pues, termina por recibir la mitad.
[De locos]
Esto - además de los impuestos, las regulaciones
laborales y, bueno, las trabas de todo tipo que
hay en el país - es precisamente lo que
explica que a pesar de los bajos costes
salariales que hoy por hoy tiene la Argentina
pues prácticamente no existan multinacionales
que quieran invertir en el país para producir
allí y luego vender al resto del mundo.
[No, claro, es que así, pues como que no.]
Pero, ojo, porque aquí no termina todo.
Dado que este tipo de políticas
han destruido su sector industrial,
la Argentina se caracteriza sobre todo por
la exportación de productos agroalimentarios,
como carne, cereales o harina. Productos
que también consumen los propios argentinos.
Pues bien, para evitar que los compradores
extranjeros compitan con los consumidores
locales, las empresas argentinas se enfrentan
a cuotas máximas de exportaciones. Es decir,
que el gobierno obliga a las empresas
a vender una parte considerable de su
producción en el mercado local, a precios,
además, fijados por el propio gobierno.
Todo esto puede parecer muy bonito. El problema,
amigos, es que reduce la entrada de
divisas, los salarios y la inversión
en incrementar la capacidad productiva.
El resultado al final es malo para todos.
Pero aún más. Durante los últimos 20
años, la exportación estrella de la
argentina ha sido la soja. Un producto
que se devora en China pero que apenas
se consume en la Argentina. Con lo cual aquí
la cuota de exportación pues no tiene sentido.
Ahora bien, ¿pensáis que esto iba a detener a los
políticos gauchos? Pues… Si es así
estáis muy pero que muy equivocados.
Los productores de soja pueden exportar toda la
soja que quieran… Pero a cambio de
pagar un impuesto extraordinario.
(Mientras que el dólar blue, que es el
dólar libre, cotiza a unos 220 pesos,
los exportadores de soja apenas reciben 70
pesos por cada dólar que exportan. Esto es
así porque el gobierno, primero, les
convierte los dólares a pesos según el
tipo de cambio oficial, y luego les
mete un impuesto adicional del 33%.
De 220 a 70 pesos por dólar exportado. )
Pero tranquilos que aún no hemos terminado.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, el gobierno
no para de aprobar nuevas barreras para
que vender al extranjero sea cada vez más
difícil. Por ejemplo, los agro-exportadores
deben estar inscritos en el llamado “Registro
de Operadores de la Cadena Agroalimentaria”.
Algo que les obliga a tener que hacer
frente a un montón de papeleo. Por ejemplo,
tienen que hacer declaraciones sobre las
ventas que planean hacer el siguiente año,
entregar información financiera para probar que
son solventes, informar detalladamente sobre
sus empleados y los salarios que paga,
verificar que las empresas con las que
interactúan también cumplan con los requisitos
del gobierno argentino, etcétera, etcétera.
Toda una pesadilla.
Y aún más. Luego una vez que ha lidiado
con el gobierno, cualquier empresa que
quiera exportar tiene que arreglarse con
el control de dos poderosos sindicatos:
el de los camioneros, liderados por el clan
Montoya y el de los empleados del puerto.
Basta deciros que la intervención de estos
sindicatos hace que el transporte en Argentina
sea particularmente caro, la competencia
limitada, y los horarios y el servicio
un desastre. Y si no te llevas bien con los
sindicatos y no les pagas las cuotas que exigen,
olvídate, porque seguramente te paren la
carga y no puedas hacer nada con ello.
Y esto son solo unos pocos ejemplos de lo
que supone el día a día. Porque sí, amigos,
ser exportador en Argentina
es casi una misión imposible.
Y los datos así lo corroboran: la
economía argentina es una de las más
cerradas al comercio internacional
de todo el mundo. Un país que ha
decidido hacer exactamente lo contrario de
lo que han hecho los países más prósperos.
Exactamente la receta contraria a la que un día
hizo de este país uno de los más ricos del mundo.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno
para ti: Con todas estas trabas,
¿Te plantearías invertir en la Argentina?
¿Qué creéis qué explica tanta obsesión
contra el comercio exterior? Dejanos
por aquí abajo tus comentarios.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.